I think the biggest discovery that's
wrapped around this revolutionary
finding of the happiness advantage their
brain works better at positive is a
recognition that our leadership needs to
change I think oftentimes we think of a
good employee or a good leader as one
that sacrifices all the type of
happiness that they can they can have to
make the company more successful when we
see individuals do that they might
thrive in a very very short period of
time but in the long run we find that
those individuals burnout their
productivity goes down their success
rates go down that can't keep clients
and their turnover rates of their
companies skyrocket you know I even
talked to this trader on Wall Street and
he said that the way that he managed as
his team one of the things he looks
around is if you see somebody that's
smiling on the trading floor he knows
they're not working hard enough that
type of mentality is the opposite of the
science that we're actually finding
about it what causes an employee to
thrive so what it means is first of all
mindset shift we need to make sure that
we're actually emphasizing the role of
social support the role of optimism that
we have in our companies that if those
starts if we sacrifice those we need to
realize that we're sacrificing the
success in the long run the second thing
that needs to happen is we need to start
doing more trainings I think a lot of
the things that we do at our companies
are focused upon the technical skills
and intelligence and if I know all the
technical skills and intelligence of an
employee I can only predict 25% of the
differences in their job successes over
the next five years
75% of our prediction of job success has
nothing to do with the technical skills
or intelligence that we normally train
people on but on three other factors the
first is the belief that your behavior
matters which is optimism levels if you
believe that your behavior matters you
keep working even the mr. challenged the
second is your social support networks
your manager your teammates your family
members and friends at home that social
support network is extremely crucial to
predicting the success rate at that
individual and the third is everyone
experiences stress but some people
experience stress as a challenge and
other people view it as a threat and
when you view your stress in a positive
way and manage your energy in a positive
way what we find is those success rates
rise so what we need to do at our
companies and at our schools as well is
to be able to focus our trainings on
that 75% on the part that actually
predicts a long-term success of not only
an individual
but an entire company I gave a talk at a
a private school and they said we know
long-term is not just the intelligence
and what we teach in the classroom this
is going to keep the success of our
individuals of our students working
really well in the workforce so once a
week or once a year we have a wellness
week where we try and cram in all the
rest of the things we don't normally
talk about and we have these experts
come in Monday night for example we have
an expert coming and speaking about
depression at Tuesday night we have
somebody talk about eating disorders and
Wednesday night is is illicit drug use
and Thursday night school violence and
team and team bullying and then Friday
night work we're trying to decide
between either having a talk on risky
sex or or happiness and I listened to
them I was like well i'm i think happy
to come speak and that sounds like most
people's friday nights but that's not oh
that's not a wellness week that's a
sickness week all we've done is we
focused upon how do we avoid all these
negative things i think what we need to
do not only our schools but our
companies worldwide is this turn our
focus upon things are our strengths not
only the individual levels when we do
performance reviews but we as leaders we
need to be able to come into a situation
and be able to realistically assess it
but also maintain the belief that our
behavior matters and focus upon those
three other elements the parts that
actually predict long-term success the
optimism the social support and our
ability to manage energy and stress in a
positive way if we do so i really
believe that the greatest competitive
advantage in the modern economy is a
positive and engaged workforce
I think one of the greatest barriers to
us not using the happiness advantage
more at our companies in our schools is
that we have a formula for success
that's this flawed almost every company
I've worked with with worldwide and over
the past two years I've traveled 42
different countries so I've seen a broad
diversity of experience and I'm finding
the same formula and almost all of them
and that is if I just work harder then
I'll be more successful and if I'm more
successful well then I'll be happier the
problem is that formula which undergirds
most of our managing styles most of our
parenting styles most of our economic
theories about how the world works our
philosophies promise that that that
formula is broken is broken
scientifically for two reasons the first
is every time we have a success our
brain merely changes the goalposts
of what that success looks like so
somebody gets into a good school well
great but they can't be happy unless
they're getting good grades
well they got good grades but that
doesn't matter because now they have to
get a good job well they got a good job
now they have to rise up in the ranks
and they have to go back to school then
they've varieties of in the ranks again
now their kids have to do well and if
happiness is on the opposite side of
success in the formula then what we've
been doing as a culture is we've been
pushing happiness over the cognitive
horizon we could keep running after it
but we'll never quite meet it the
biggest problem though is that the
formula works in the opposite direction
all the science we've been doing in the
field of positive psychology over the
past 10 to 15 years has found this that
your brain works better faster more
accurately with more energy when you're
positive as opposed to negative neutral
stressed which means the formula
actually works if you can raise up your
levels of happiness your levels of
well-being your levels of positivity
then your success rates rise and then
you're able to work harder and faster
there's a conference board survey that
came out in January of this year
reporting that even in the midst of high
unemployment we're seeing the greatest
amount of job dissatisfaction in 22
years of polling I think the reason for
this is that most of our companies in
schools we find ourselves chasing after
so hard a happiness that seems elusive
when if we change the formula and
actually focus our time energy and
priorities are raising up our levels of
happiness we then see those success
rates rise not only the end of it
level but at the company level as well